our friend Armando Salguero of the Miami
Herald recently suggested the dolphins
may be plotting a move up to the top of
the draft to get Joe Borough we reported
weeks ago that Stephen Ross the owner of
the Dolphins wants Joe borough and that
thought kind of subsided during the
chatter in late January early February
whether or not Joe borough wants to
avoid playing for the Bengals the bottom
line is Stephen Ross still wants Joe
borough and maybe there will be an
effort to trade up to get him Peters is
a good idea when you consider the draft
capital bid presumably is gonna have to
be surrendered remember it was 2012
where Washington gave up the sixth
overall pick and two additional first
rounders and a second-round pick to go
from 6 to 2 to get RG 3 is it worth
giving up multiple first-round picks and
more to get the quarterback that you
want and only move up a total of four
spots from five up to number one Mike
the only way that if I were the Bengals
that I would consider this even consider
this is if the Miami Dolphins said we'll
give you four ones for the first pick in
the draft and what that means is it you
you use five eighteen and twenty six
this year and whatever your one is next
year okay so and what that would mean
because I think we all would probably
think that the Dolphins will be
somewhere around five hundred this year
so let's just say I'll ask you this
question in a practical manner if you
have the first pick in the draft this
year and you thought you had your
quarterback of the future in Joe burrow
if you had that would you trade it for
five eighteen twenty six and sixteen
next year would you do that yeah and you
know what that's the right way to look
at it you're not trading for the spot
you're trading for the player and during
the season we had an extended debate on
which players in the NFL you currently
would trade to first-round picks in a
fourth round pick four cuz Jalen Ramsey
netted that when you think of it as in
unproven commodity that's a lot to give
up Peter you better be damn sure he's
the guy and also maybe in this crazy
upside-down world that we're in where
you can't do as much as you'd like to
with the draft with the preparation and
the planning for the draft
maybe those picks aren't as valuable as
they would be in other years and maybe
if you are a believer that Joe burrow is
the real thing you're more comfortable
giving up those picks because you're not
going to get the same value out of those
picks that you ordinarily would Mike
there's one other point too to consider
here okay so Mike Tannenbaum who
obviously is the former general manager
of the Miami Dolphins walked out of that
organization convinced convinced that in
one of these drafts you know post
Tannenbaum that they were going to do
everything that they could that Stephen
Ross above all other things even putting
the team in a hole for a little while
above all other things
wanted to get his long-term quarterback
soon very soon if that's the case and I
absolutely believe that to be the case
that if Stephen Ross's mantra is we need
a quarterback and we have to do whatever
it takes
they've been collecting all these high
picks Minka Fitzpatrick they're
collecting picks Laremy Tunsil they're
collecting they're collecting all these
picks to get a guy now if your guy is
Joe burrow why would any price be too
high in essence and I'll just say one
other thing what if you're the Miami
Dolphins and you really like to a tongue
of Aloha and you kind of like Justin
Herbert but you don't have deep down the
feeling about those two quarterbacks
that you have about Joe burrow then it's
worth it to pay the insurance to get the
guy you're absolutely sure about yeah I
I agree with you there and we'll see how
it all plays
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports